♪ ♪
>> Juan: OH, BOY, ARE WE ON
THE VERGE OF ANOTHER
CONSERVATIVE COMEBACK?
"LAST MAN STANDING" HEADED BACK
TO TV.
FOX IS REVIVING THE SERIES,
SECOND HIGHEST RATED COMEDY ON
ABC BEFORE WAS CANCELED AFTER A
SIX SEASON RUN.
A FOX TV EXECUTIVE SAYS THAT THE
SUCCESS OF ROSANNE'S REBOOT HAS
EMBOLDENED THEM TO BRING TIM
ALLEN BACK.
ANOTHER FOX EXECUTIVE SAYS THE
SHOW WASN'T CANCELED BECAUSE OF
THE POLITICS.
IN ANY CASE, HERE IS A SNEAK
PEEK AT THE REBOOT.
>> THE BEST DAY EVER.
>> WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN DOING?
>> HONEY, ONLY ASK QUESTIONS YOU
REALLY WANT ANSWERS TO.
DO YOU THINK I AM TOO
AFFECTIONATE?
>> YES.
THAT IS THE BEEF EVERYBODY HAS
WITH YOU.
>> THERE IS ONLY ONE BOOK YOU
HAVE TO FOLLOW WORD FOR WORD.
>> THE BIBLE.
>> THE FEDERAL TAX CODE.
>> Juan: HE HAS BEEN A TRUMP
SUPPORTER ALL ALONG, AND NOW
HE'S COMING BACK.
IN LIGHT OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> Greg: I DON'T REMEMBER HIS
SHOW BEING CONSERVATIVE
POLITICALLY.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE SHOW IS
HERE, CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE IT'S
NOT SO ANNOYINGLY LIBERAL.
HOLLYWOOD IS SO FAR LEFT, THIS
BEING NORMAL, WHICH IS WHAT THAT
SHOW APPEARS TO BECOME A NORMAL
COMMON SENSE, IS NOW RIGHT WING.
THAT IS THE STORY.
>> Juan: DANA, IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
AT ROSEANN SAY THEY ARE GOING TO
DO MORE FAMILY STUFF, LESS
POLITICS, AND GREG MAKES THE
POINT THAT SHOWED TO HIM WASN'T
ALL THAT POLITICAL.
>> Dana: RIGHT, I THINK IN
SOME WAYS JUST BECAUSE OF MAYBE
THE WAY THINGS HAVE BEEN THE
LAST THREE YEARS, WE ARE COMING
UP ON THE THREE YEARS SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT DOWN THE
ESCALATOR.
WE ARE SEEING EVERYTHING THROUGH
SOME SORT OF POLITICAL LENS WHEN
MAYBE IT DOESN'T EVEN REALLY
HAVE TO BE THAT WAY.
IT COULD BE THAT FOX THINKS THAT
IT CAN MAKE MONEY HAVING TIM
ALLEN'S SHOW BACK ON AIR, THAT'S
A GOOD BUSINESS DECISION AND
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO DO
WITH POLITICS.
THERE WAS AN OUTCRY WHEN IT WAS
CANCELED.
I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY A GOOD
BUSINESS MOVE.
NOT NECESSARILY A POLITICAL ONE.
>> Kimberly: WELL REASONED AND
WELL STATED.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Juan: THE IMPACT ON US IS
THAT THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL IS
GOING TO BE ON FOX THEY'RE GOING
TO ABSOLUTELY USE THAT TO LAUNCH
THEIR FRIDAY NIGHT SCHEDULE,
INCLUDING MR. ALLEN.
>> Kimberly: KIMBERLY, BIG
49ers FAN.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
TIM ALLEN?
DO YOU THINK IT'S ABOUT A
CONSERVATIVE RESURGENCE?
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF HE
WAS A REAL CONSERVATIVE ADVOCATE
WHEN HE WAS ON THE AIR.
I KNOW OFF THE AIR, HE IS BUT I
THINK LIGHTS GO OFF IN HOLLYWOOD
SAYS THERE'S 60 MILLION
REPUBLICAN VOTERS AND THEY ALL
HAVE TVs.
LIKE DANA SAID, IT'S THAT THIS
DECISION.
CONSERVATIVE ENTERTAINMENT DOES
VERY WELL.
POLITICS IS FUNNY.
JON STEWART DOES WELL.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" DOES WELL.
GREG GUTFELD, WATTERS' WORLD.
TUCKER CARLSON.
IT'S A RIOT.
THERE IS AN APPETITE FOR
POLITICS AND HUMOR, AND PEOPLE
FOR A LONG TIME AND HOLLYWOOD
TRIED TO KEEP DOWN CONSERVATIVE
TALENTS BECAUSE THEY WERE ALWAYS
SUPPOSED TO BE MARGINALIZED AND
RIDICULED.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
CONSERVATIVE VOICE GLAMORIZED
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO TRY TO
SIDELINE THOSE VOICES.
NOW MONEY TALKS.
>> Kimberly: IT IS LIKE FIELD
OF DREAMS.
THEY BUILT A MEGA-HOME AND THEY
WENT.
YOU GIVE THEM A PLACE TO WATCH
AND VIEW A LEG ROSEANNE, WHY
WOULDN'T YOU TRY TO CAPTURE THAT
PART OF THE MARKET?
MAKES PERFECT BUSINESS SENSE.
TIM ALLEN IS INCREDIBLY TALENTED
IN THE SHOW WAS WELL RECEIVED.
I THINK OF THE SMART BUSINESS
DECISION.
>> Dana: WE SHOULD HAVE THEM
ON THE SHOW FOR A SEGMENT ONE
DAY.
>> Jesse: ALREADY BOOKED ON
WATTERS' WORLD.
>> Kimberly: WITH SEBASTIAN